i get requests for different pictures
and i sell them and make money 90 day
fiance star elizabeth's family keeps the
revelations coming i definitely am i'm
not holding back elizabeth and her
husband andre appear on the season 2
premiere of 90 day bears all on
discovery plus alongside her sisters jen
and becky elizabeth's estranged brother
charlie's wife megan also made a
surprise appearance i still to this day
don't know why
everyone in the family stopped talking
to me first let's understand the back
story here charlie revealed on the 90
day fiance happily ever after tell-all
special that aired in august that his
family had stopped talking to him
following his fist fight with andre at a
family barbecue
what are you doing stop stop stop stop
and his family in turn accused him of
having issues with alcohol do you think
charlie abuses alcohol
um i don't think he has a good
relationship with alcohol
they try to cancel me out the family and
meghan said that despite being longtime
best friends with jen the family cut her
off as well we've been together 20 years
he's always been the same charlie and
he's he speaks his mind and that's what
i love about him and you know they all
know what charlie has been like you know
he doesn't hold back
and
i guess they all just got the point
where
they decided let's just cancel charlie
out of the family which means myself and
our four kids as well but jen said
charlie made her two daughters cry at a
barbecue which is when she decided to
distance herself from the couple and she
said she explained that to megan as for
elizabeth she said her relationship with
charlie changed when he drunkenly called
out andre and made an embarrassing scene
at their wedding
i just said he needed to stop
paying for your boat
i think that was uh expensive like
my dad
has like seven kids
so it's like did you do this for every
other kid
no you didn't
so you know
it's like
why are you doing this for him
like why why he's my dad he's paying for
my wedding and
that's okay if he wants to do that
that's up to him it's not like i begged
him or anything i just asked him he
could have said no if he wanted to but
he did it because i'm his daughter and
he loves me and that's that it's not
taking advantage so clearly the family
drama isn't getting resolved anytime
soon but that wasn't the only big
takeaway i get requests for different
pictures and i sell them and make money
okay so how did you get into that uh
actually the girls yep megan said while
charlie was filming the tell-all in new
york she was selling pictures of her
feet and she claims elizabeth jenn and
becky got her into it they can call me
trash all they want
but
they started before me the three women
denied ever selling pictures of their
feet and when becky threatened to sue
megan for telling a lie megan had this
to say i know you sell other pictures
it's more than just feet but anyway
if people like my feet some people have
foot fetishes why not make money i would
have never thought i could make money
from selling foot pictures but foot
modeling is a thing and if i can make
money
why not and it didn't stop there megan
said she takes requests like showing the
soles of her feet or dirtying up her
feet and she said she's made over a
thousand dollars a day selling those
snaps that's when andre claimed megan
sells a whole lot more than pictures of
her feet
that's it right that's it you're broke
and you're reporting a star megan
brushed off those claims but did admit
to selling pictures of her breasts i
mean i'll do like sexy videos and
lingerie stuff like that i don't find
feet sexual i don't find your stomach
sexual my boobs are freaking fake you
can't make this stuff up people honestly
like a part of me almost wishes that it
was scripted so i wouldn't have to go
through all of this
crap that i'm going through and when it
caught up with elizabeth and andre in
june they said drama is just part of the
territory when you have a big family i
think they're coming from a family of
like a lot of people and their fights
already are so
you know like they're so used to those
fights my family has always been
somewhat chaotic and we've always had
our riff rafts and they're like oh let's
square it up and after this the second
day they're like oh let's just you know
like get some makeup
[Music]